So how might you use the idea of configuration to design an agent that can
answer Raven's progressive matrices? We've talked in the past about how
constraint propagation can help us solving these problems. If configuration is
a type of constraint propagation, how can you leverage the idea of variables and
values in designing your agent? What are the variables and
what values can they take? We've also discussed how planning can be applied to
Raven's progressive matrices. If configuration leverages old plans,
how you build your agent to remember those old plans and reconfigure them for
new problems? Will it develop the old plans based on existing problems, or
will you hand it the problems in advance?